[Music]
hey Luke here at the outdoor woods
YouTube channel I'm going to show you
some epic knife work
the me my family took this awesome
halibut fishing charter with puffin
charters in Seward Alaska we brought
back a ton of fish and the boys at
puffin charters laid it all up for us
and I got to tell you it was some of the
most impressive knife work I have ever
seen so check this out these guys know
how to play halibut
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
why
these guys were so fast and so smooth
and you look at these carcasses and
there is just zero
wasted meat look at that and I couldn't
get get it that close to the bone if I
spent all day doing it and these guys
flayed up 12 halibut in about 10 minutes
and something like 13 rockfish as well
it was it was great well thanks for
watching I hope you enjoyed this video
if you'd like to see more videos from
the outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every week and check the video
description for a link to our Alaska
adventure series thanks for watching
[Music]